Facebook und Google haben leichtes Spiel:
Wer auf den Plattformen Daten hinterlässt,
der gibt freiwillig Informationen preis.
Die Unternehmen können sie nutzen
und mit ihrer Hilfe Werbung generieren –
doch gehören ihnen deshalb die Daten?
Zumindest in der EU gibt es
ein neues Gesetz:
Eigentümer bleiben die User.
Doch müssten die dann nicht
auch mitverdienen?
Das deutsch-amerikanische Start-up
Datawallet hat dafür
ein Geschäftsmodell entwickelt.
Die User bekommen einen Anteil,
wenn ihre Daten verkauft werden.
Wenn wir in fünf bis zehn Jahren
zurückblicken,
wird uns das heute vorkommen
wie das finstere Mittelalter der Daten,
als wir keinerlei Kontrolle hatten
und im Grunde jeder unsere Daten
beanspruchen konnte
und wir keinen Einfluss darauf hatten.
In Zukunft werden Daten eines
der wichtigsten Güter für Menschen sein
und auch eine Einnahmequelle,
von der sie leben können.
Außerhalb der EU gelten weniger
strenge Datenschutzgesetze,
zum Beispiel in den USA.
In vielen Ländern gibt es
überhaupt keine Regelungen.
Datawallet will Daten bündeln
und die User selbst entscheiden lassen,
wer sie nutzen darf.
Denn die Datenmenge ist riesig.
Soziale Netzwerke sammeln
Kommentare, Statusmeldungen, Likes –
und sie können daraus
Emotionen ablesen.
Informationen kommen auch aus
hochgeladenen Fotos.
Online-Shops sammeln Informationen
über unsere Einkaufsvorlieben
und unseren Lebensstil.
Wer sich bei Partnerbörsen
oder Online-Foren anmeldet,
gibt seine Einstellungen preis.
Wer Rabattkarten nutzt, teilt mit,
wie viel Geld er ausgibt.
Doch richtig lukrativ wird es erst,
wenn die Datenflut aufbereitet wird.
Das übernehmen sogenannte
Daten-Broker.
Sie kaufen die Daten auf und versuchen
mit Hilfe von Big-Data-Analysen,
Zusammenhänge herzustellen.
Daraus entsteht eine Art
digitaler Steckbrief.
So ein Profil beschreibt einen Menschen,
beschreibt Ängste,
beschreibt Bedürfnisse,
beschreibt vielleicht eine finanzielle Lage,
um entsprechend Werbung
auch auf den Geldbeutel zugeschnitten
schalten zu können;
beschreibt uns so gut, wie es selbst
unsere besten Freunde kaum könnten.
Karsten Nohl ist Spezialist
für Datensicherheit.
Seine Firma berät Unternehmen.
Den globalen Datenhandel sieht er kritisch.
Denn es ist ein Milliardengeschäft –
allerdings nur für wenige.
Google allein als eine Firma
verdient im Jahr
über 100 Milliarden Dollar
mit geschalteter Werbung.
Diese 100 Milliarden Dollar müssen natürlich
irgendwo wieder reingeholt werden
durch Produkte,
die dann auf Basis dieser Werbung
geschaltet [gekauft] werden.
Das heißt, eine einzelne Firma verdient
an jedem Nutzer
hunderte bis tausende Dollar pro Jahr.
Datawallet dreht nun den Spieß um.
Über die Webseite der Firma können
die User ihre Daten selbst verwalten
und bekommen einen Anteil
beim Verkauf ihrer Daten.
Noch ist Datawallet zu klein,
um Facebook oder Google
gefährlich zu werden.
Dass die Giganten Daten sammeln,
können sie nicht verhindern,
doch sie wollen Fairness.
Im Grunde bieten wir den Leuten an,
all ihre Daten,
die sie im Internet erzeugt haben
auf sämtlichen Plattformen,
die sie nutzen,
in ein Profil zu speichern
und sie dann mit den Firmen zu teilen,
die sie gut finden.
Wer ein Datenprofil bei uns hat,
kann es an eine Firma oder
auch an fünfzig verkaufen.
Was Datawallet vorhat, ist visionär –
ein Eigentumsrecht an den eigenen Daten
und die Möglichkeit,
an ihnen mitzuverdienen.